there are very strong stereotypes of
adolescents often quite negative
stereotypes you see them in the media
now you also see them back in in in
Shakespeare and even in Plato and
Aristotle these stereotypes that
adolescents being badly behaved making
silly decisions taking lots of risks
lazy irresponsible antisocial rude
disrespectful high-maintenance those
stereotypes are based partly in some
reality there is some evidence that
adolescents take more risks than other
age groups Ravel years one of the kind
of nuances that the stereotype misses
out is the context that risk-taking
tends to take place in so if you think
about adolescent typical risk-taking
ones like smoking and drinking alcohol
and experimenting with drugs dangerous
driving those kinds of risks don't tend
to take place when their young person is
on their own
it's normally when they're with their
friends and there's a lot of evidence
from many different labs around the
world that adolescents are particularly
influenced by their peers I don't think
I particularly take risks although I
have done small things like drunk a lot
of ketchup before I didn't know how much
to take so I didn't want like always
taking too little too much so I just
took oh if I wasn't my own I wouldn't
also be no need to I don't like ketchup
so for example sticking with the example
of driving risks a classic experiment
which has now been replicated several
times by Larry Steinberg and his
colleagues has shown that if you bring
people into the lab you get them to play
a driving video game we have to get
around a circuit as quickly as possible
you find that actually interestingly the
number of risks that different age
groups take is around the same number
when they're on their own but if the
participant has a couple of friends
standing behind them that significantly
increases the number of driving risks
adolescents take and young adults take
under the age of twenty five
but it has no effect on the number of
risks that adults over the age of 25
take in terms of the experiments we've
done in my lab we often look at things
like social influence and one of one of
the experiments we did looked at social
influence on risk perception so here
were here we were asking participants to
rate how risky they think different
everyday situations are so things like
driving without a seatbelt or crossing a
street on a red light or cycling without
helmet the critical finding in this
experiment was that young adolescents
aged 12 to 14 are more influenced by
people their own age by other teenagers
and that wasn't true for any other age
groups her children and older
adolescents and adults are more likely
to be influenced by adults than by
teenagers my friends are very important
to me because they they're like I see
them almost every single day and like
they just they make me feel safe as well
if I don't have my friends sometimes I
look a little bit lost one of the things
that matters in adolescents is to be
accepted by your peer group and not to
be excluded by your peers so we know
from work by kat sebastian and other
people that adolescents are
hypersensitive to social exclusion
people aren't being accepted for who
they are and they're being forced to
change in like big things like social
media affecting this like you don't have
social media people are going to exclude
you who you are even though they
shouldn't so people change who they are
to fit in what it means is that they're
going to pay more attention to their own
peers than they are to adults so if
you're if you're organizing say a health
campaign aimed at young people what
seems to matter most is changing social
norms and educating young people
themselves to run campaigns anti smoking
or anti-bullying campaigns that has a
much bigger impact on young people's
attitudes towards things like smoking
and bullying than adults running the
same kind of campaigns that absolutely
fits with the new neuroscience
showing that social influence has the
biggest effect on adolescent
making a mistaken bigger than other
other influences I think one thing I
would have really appreciated knowing
about during my teenage years was how
the brain develops during adolescence
and how this is a period of life where
everything is quite unstable both in
terms of your social world and your
biology or your hormones and your and
your brain and that's a very natural
adaptive developmental period where
things are changing and where you'll
come out the other end of Earth
independent adult
[Music]
you
[Music]